في موضوع صحي غذائي لكن بنكهه تقنيه تحمل
وصفه اعدها وحددها ومن غيرها الان هو حديث
الساعه المنافس لعقل الانسان الذكاء
الاصطناعي اليوم مشاهدينا تسود حاله من
الجدل في اوساط علماء الصحه مع دخول
الذكاء الاصطناعي متمثلا في تشات جي بي تي
في مساله الحميه الغذائيه واقتراح هذه
الحميه المناسبه التجربه جاءت من محرر
موقع ديلي ميل البريطاني الذي سال روبوت
الدردشه الشهير عن حميه مناسبه تراعي
السعرات الحراريه روبوت دردشه شهير نصح
باتباع نظام البحر الابيض المتوسط الغذائي
لاجل ضمان حميه مناسبه هذا التحديد اثار
الجدل بين خبراء التغذيه حيث يرى البعض
انه
اقدم انماط او ان قدم
البعض يرى انه ان ماط الاكل كثيره
والجبيتشات قدم انماط الاكل الصحيه على
الكوكب اختار النموذج الاقدم يعني
فعلا حميه صحيه كتير بس مش بالضروره
مناسبه للجميع على كل حال اخرين مشاهدينا
يخشون من فشل الخطه وعدم القدره على
تطبيقها سواء من ناحيه تكلفتها من ناحيه
تكلفتها او حتى طريقتها
خلينا بس نقول بانه بالنسبه لي حميه
غذائيه من غير رز ما تعتبر رز على الصبح
الفطور
للناس فيما يعشقون مذاهبه
خلينا نراجع سويا يعني السبعه ايام بصحبه
الحميه التي اقترحها تشاد جي بي تي التي
جاء فيها كالتالي اليوم الاول يجب ان
يعتمد على بعض الزبادي اليوناني واللوز
والخبز المحمص القليل من الدجاج والطماطم
وزيت الزيتون وعصير الليمون وسمك السالمون
انا شبعت يعني اول يوم على كل حال في
اليوم الثاني مشاهدينا يحتوي ايضا على
العجه النباتيه ايضا خبز الحبوب الكامله
شرائح الدجاجه المشوي السلطه الخضراء
والمشكله ايضا فضلا عن البطاطا الحلوه او
عفوا الخضره المشكله وايضا البطاطا الحلوه
والبروكلي طيب ثالث يوم يحتوي على رقائق
الشوفان بذور الشيا والخضروات وجبنه الفته
والروبيان المشوي والحبوب الكامل
اما في اليوم الرابع يتكون من افوكادو
وخبز محمص وعدس وبعض شرائح اللحم المشوي
والزيت الزيتون والثوم ايضا اليوم الخامس
مفترض هذا اليوم يحتوي على سبانخ الفطر
البطيخ خضروات مشكله حمص اضافه لزيت
الزيتون وسمك القدم المشوي على اليوم
السادس جعت انا بعد ما شبعت اول يوم لانه
اليوم السادس مشاهدينا بحسب
يدخل فيه الشوفان والخوخ والعسل واللوز
ايضا مع لفائف خضروات مشويه هذا بالاضافه
الى دجاج مشوي وخضار مشوي ايضا اليوم
السابع وهو اليوم الجد خلاص اليوم السابع
سنعود للزبادي اليوناني ولكن بالعسل مع
شرائح اللوز وفلفل محشي بالكينوه وسلطه
يونانيه وسمك مشوي وقشر ليمون
والاعشاب مع ذرع مشوي
[موسيقى]
انا لا ما بفضل انه الذكاء الاصطنا
السيطره على وجبات الغذائيه فانا بحب انه
يكون في دكتور متابعيني شخصيا بورجيه
فحوصاتي اول باول لا طبعا ما بخليه يسيطر
على وجبات اليوميه لانه بتعرفي البني ادم
يعني له طاقه بالاكل وبالشغل ممكن يساعدني
اني اعمل دايت باكلي
كتير بيساعدني في تجربه جديده الواحد
يجربها نهايه اذا زبطت معه اوكي ما زبطت
معه بكون جربه وخلص اخذت خبره على الموضوع
اوافق الذكاء الاصطناعي باشياء توافق
تغيري الطب تقدم صناعه بالشركات هيك شغلات
يعني اما في الطب انا افضل الدكتور صراحه
يعني قد ما كان الذكاء الاصطناعي ما راح
يوصل مخ الانسان صح ولا لا بعدين غير عليك
يعني بصراحه انا بدي اكل اللي بدي اياه ما
بقدر اخيرني يعني
المشاهدين في الاستوديو اختصاصيه التغذيه
نور جهاد اهلا بك يا نور معنا في صباح
العربيه صباح الخير صباح الخير
على فكره مش برنامج غذائي يعني ناكله بين
الوجبات المفترض
هلا قرات الشغلات والله
طب خليني ادخل في الموضوع على طول الموضوع
هو هل تستطيع تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي
انهم يحددوا لنا
بكفاءه نظام تغذيه مناسب لالنا يعني انا
بصراحه متخوفه من هذا الموضوع خصوصا انه
يعني ذكاء الاصطناعي دخل بكل شيء بعتقد في
اماكن مش مكانه
احنا كاخصائيين تغذيه منعاني من موضوع
الحميات الموجوده على الانترنت من زمان
يعني في عندنا حملات موجوده على الانترنت
نحط 5 كيلو بخمسه ايام او عشره كيلو ب 10
ايام وهلا راويه صارت الموضوع مختلف انه
انا في روبوت قاعد عم بجاوبني خلال ثواني
مجرد ما انه انا خطرت ببالي الفكره راح
اساله سؤال وراح اجاوبني وفعلا هو بيعطي
حميات غذائيه ولكن السؤال هل هو فعلا ممكن
ينزلني وزن ولا ممكن انه ما ينزلني وزن
الاجابه هي نعم ولا
ممكن انه يزبط مع اشخاص ينزل بس في اشخاص
ثانيين ممكن ما ينزل وزنهم لانه عاده نظام
ممكن انه يعطيني حميه غذائيه او نفس
الحميه الغذائيه لاكثر من شخص واحنا
كاخصائيين تغذيه بنتعامل مع اجسام مختلفه
وبنعطي حملات غذائيه بناء على طبيعه
الاجسام ما هي الاخطاء اللي من الممكن انه
التشات يسببها لنا اذا انا اعتمدت عليه
وما رحت لنور حتى تعطيني هذه الوصفه
السحريه اللي راح اضعف من خلالها هلا عادل
خلينا نحكي عن سلبيات اكثر من انه
اخطات نظام غذائي
لا اكثر فهل من اهم السلبيات وكمان في عنا
الجي بيتي او تشاد جي بي تي يعتمد على
الدراسات علميه ولكن للاسف هاي الدراسات
ممكن انها تكون ضعيفه احنا عندنا الدراسات
العلميه بتصنف للدراسات قويه ضعيفه ممكن
تكون متوسطه ممكن انه يعطيني حمله غذائيه
او يعطيني معلومه طبيه او تغذيه من دراسه
علميه ضعيفه واحنا كخصائيين تغذيه دراسات
العلميه متجدده والاهم من هيك انه نظام
معطيني دراسات وبجاوبني بناء على دراسات
ولكن لغايه سنه 20 21 فاي دراسه من سنه
2022 سنه 20 23 ما رح يدخلني فيها واحنا
بالتغذيه نظامنا او العلم هذا متجدد كل
سنه او كل شهر ممكن يطلع لي دراسه علميه
مختلفه ممكن تلغي لي الدراسه اللي كانت
قبلها
من اهم الحقيقه لفتني يا نور وراح نجرب
كمان شوي ندخل على التشات بس انا جربت ما
بياخد ما بيطلب مني اي معلومات لا عمري
ولا وزني ولا شو التارجت يعني الوزن اللي
انا بطمح اني اوصل له ولا اشي بس طلبت منه
انه يعطيني حميه هلا رح نجرب وبلش يكتب
طيب هلا انتم بتعملوا فحص سريري عاده
بتاخذوا معلومات وافيه عن الشخص الامراض
الموجوده بتعملوا فحوصات معينه
بتعرفوا شو المشكله راويه انه ممكن فيه
باوقات انه يسالني بتعاني من امراض معينه
المشكله انه الشخص نفسه ممكن ما يكون بعرف
انه بعاني من مرض معين ولكن من خلال
التشخيص الطبي والتغذوي انا كخصائيه تغذيه
ممكن اميز انه هذا الشخص من خلال واعراض
معينه انه هو بيكون بعاني من اعراض معينه
ولكن تشارجي بتصير يمكن ما يتميز هذا
الشيء بيعطيني حمله غذائيه مش مناسبه لالي
غير راويه مثل هلا انت ذكرتي الفحص
السريري احنا عندنا بعيادات التغذيه في
عنا جهاز لفحص مكونات الجسم بعرف من خلاله
100% نسبه الدهون بعرف من خلاله وين
الدهون متركزه فمثلا لو كانت الدهون
متركزه عند منطقه البطن انا رح اعطي حميه
غذائيه بناء على الفحص مكونات هذه طيب خلي
التجربه انا كتبت له هل ممكن ان تعطيني
حميه غذائيه مناسبه طيب
طيب خليها بهذا الاتجاه ايوه
ولا سؤال عندي عطل عطني باتجاهي يلا نشوف
ما سالني ولا سؤال على فكره ولا اشي انا
كتبت له هاي الجمله بلشنا كتب لي انه اكيد
بالطبع ها هي حميه غذائيه مناسبه لك بعرف
كيف عرف انها مناسبه لالي ولكن وبلاش يكتب
هاي الافطار وجبه الغداء الافطار اعطاني
شوفان مع الفواكه مثلا بيضتين مسلوقات في
الغذاء الغداء وجبه الغداء سلطه الدجاج
المشويه طبق سمك مشوي وجبه العشاء صحن
دجاج المقلي والخفيف
شلون تعرف تناسبني كيف تعرف انها تناسبني
[ضحك]
تخلصين هل
وانا عادي لازم انوه لموضوع احنا ما بنعطي
حميه غذائيه نعطيها زي ما حكيت راويه بناء
على طول على العمر على الوزن وعلى الحاله
الصحيه اوكي خليني اقول لكم شو كتب لمعرفه
ما اذا كانت الحميه الغذائيه مناسبه لك
يمكنك اخذ بعض العوامل في الاعتبار الهدف
الغذائي الحاله الصحيه تفضيلاتك انت
والنشاط البدني
الاصطناعي ممكن يعطيكم
حميه غذائيه ولكنها ليست مفصله لكم هي
بشكل عام جدا وعمومك الحلو في هذه التجربه
نروي قرات من غير نظاره طيب شكرا
جزيلا يعطيك العافيه
الاختصاصيه التغذيه نور جهات شكرا جزيلا
لك شكرا يا نور لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات